Both of us had retired not too long before
we started coming to MoMA and neither one
of us,
I think, would have envisioned that this would
be something we really got excited about.
Not that we didn't appreciate art before,
but participating -- we both didn't see ourselves
as doing this. You know, we just would have
felt "that's not us, we can't do that."
But it's given us a new -- something new,
so we love it.
Well, for me the experience of art-making
is the taking of myself out of myself -- my
norm. Putting myself into another dimension,
partially which I occasionally fantasize about,
this becomes a reality for me.
And partly, something I am tempted to do but
frequently don't have the determination or
guts to do. And so it gives me the opportunity
to take a chance, based upon the circumstances
that I have to do it, that I'm forced to do
it, I do it the best I can. Part of my philosophy
in life is to constantly seek out and overcome
challenges.
Hello. I am Laurel Humble
Hi I'm Meryl Schwartz and we work on The MoMA
Alzheimer's Project within the Department
of Education at The Museum of Modern Art.
Funded by a major grant from MetLife Foundation,
The MoMA Alzheimer's Project allows Meryl
and me and our colleagues in the Department
of Education to develop art discussion and
art-making programs for people with Alzheimer's
disease and their carepartners. We teach these
programs here onsite in the Museum's galleries
and studio spaces, and also offsite in care
facilities around the city.
Based on our work with this audience, we also
lead training workshops for arts and health
professionals, and have developed educational
resources used by staff of museums, care facilities,
and other community organizations serving
people with dementia and their carepartners.
And one of these resources is this video!
This video is for people involved in dementia
care or museum and arts education who want
to learn more about how to facilitate an art-making
program with people with Alzheimer's disease.
It is designed for individuals with varying
personal and professional expertise, who are
likely working in a variety of settings, each
with their own logistical considerations,
such as spaces, time, and budget.
Accordingly, we've chosen not to focus on
those aspects of programming.
Instead we'll focus on the teaching strategies
and other tools necessary for leading a successful
art-making program, including:
Some background information, like general
information on dementia and MoMA's program
structure and approach, and the role of the
educator in creating a successful experience
How you as an educator conceive of and prepare
for your project
How to lead your project, step by step
And general tips for facilitating successful
art-making programs as well as tools for troubleshooting
challenging scenarios
Throughout we'll include program footage and
anecdotes from our experiences.
While our discussion will be framed by our
perspectives as museum educators working with
groups in our studio spaces, the techniques
we will discuss are applicable to any setting
or situation, so long as you can access art-making
materials and have a bit of space to work.
In addition, we encourage you to think of
about these programs as an opportunity for
you to learn and grow. This approach should
inform the decisions you make in your planning
and facilitation. Throughout we will emphasize
the importance of developing projects that
you, as the educator, find interesting as
well.
In the end we hope that you will feel confident
in your ability to facilitate a meaningful
art-making program that leads to new understandings
about the creative process and prompts new
social connections among participants.
ART MAKING
BACKGROUND INFORMATION
In this section, we'll give you some background
information to consider when planning art-making
programs for people with Alzheimer's disease,
including what our typical program structure
includes, benefits of engaging with art in
general, basic information about Alzheimer's
disease and other forms of dementia, including
which symptoms we most frequently encounter,
and finally, a general overview of what you
can do as an educator to create a successful
experience.
Let's start with an overview of MoMA's art
making programs for individuals with Alzheimer's
disease and their carepartners.
Our art-making programs last about 1 ½ to
2 hours and are taught by an educator with
additional help from support staff or volunteers.
At the start, the educator outlines the main
ideas in the chosen project. They then facilitate
a brief discussion of a few related works
from the Museum's collection.
Afterwards, they distribute materials and
give participants ample time to create their
own works. In the end participants discuss
their works together. Finally, the educator
concludes the program by providing last thoughts
and suggestions for future art-making opportunities.
Whenever possible we hold an exhibition to
share the participant artwork with a greater
audience.
The program structure and the teaching techniques
we use are well established in museum education.
In fact, we use them in MoMA's education programs
for people of all ages and abilities.
This is because we recognize that engaging
with art by making works allows all people
the chance to express ideas, talents, and
experiences,
Create an original object that is unique to
them,
Experience both tactile and intellectual stimulation
simultaneously,
Reflect on their creation within a greater
context of artistic practice,
Explore and exchange ideas with other people
in a social environment,
And finally, to participate in a meaningful
activity that fosters personal growth,
These benefits apply no matter who the audience
is, but they are particularly significant
for individuals with Alzheimer's disease who
might be experiencing a dearth of opportunities
for cultural engagement and personal development.
With a diagnosis of Alzheimer's disease there
can be an assumption that people are no longer
able to learn or they won't benefit from exposure
to new experiences. But surely the desire
for personal growth and development remains,
and participating in arts engagement programs
can satisfy these lifelong needs.
Moreover, making art is particularly well-suited
for engaging people with Alzheimer's disease
because the process of creation doesn't necessarily
require short term memory. You work on a physical
object that remains in front of you, and you
continue to develop that object in real time.
Short term memory loss is one of the main
symptoms of Alzheimer's disease, but it isn't
the only one. We'll talk about some of the
symptoms you may encounter when working with
this audience, but first, let's start with
the basics:
Dementia is a general term for a group of
brain disorders. Alzheimer's disease is the
most common form of dementia. All types of
dementia impair mental functioning and are
severe enough to interfere with usual activities
of daily life. Dementia may also affect language,
visuospatial functioning and executive functioning.
Some of you may already have a great deal
of experience working with people with Alzheimer's
disease or other forms of dementia, while
others may not. There are a number of resources
you can turn to to find out more, including
your local medical professionals, hospitals
or care facilities, your local chapter of
the Alzheimer's Association, or the National
Institute on Aging's Alzheimer's Disease Education
and Referral Center.
In our experience symptoms differ from person
to person and many challenging behaviors can
be circumvented through your planning and
facilitation of the experience, as well as
the tone you set as the educator.
Overall, these are the symptoms we've most
frequently encountered in our art making programs
for people with early to mid stage Alzheimer's
disease:
The first is memory loss. Forgetting recently
learned information is one of the most common
symptoms of Alzheimer's disease. Participants
may not remember things you or other participants
have said, including the guidelines for the
project at hand.
We've also experienced difficulties with language.
As you are conversing, it may, at times, be
hard to understand a participant's words.
Participants may forget words or make unusual
substitutions. Some participants may have
lost significant verbal ability.
We've also experienced difficulties with visuospatial
thinking. Participants may have difficulty
navigating your set up and spaces. They may
also have trouble handling certain materials.
Another symptom you may encounter is apathy.
Some participants may need additional or continued
prompting to remain engaged.
On the other hand, some participants may demonstrate
a lack of inhibition or have trouble with
impulse control. While some participants are
more inhibited, others may be candid or unreserved.
In the Tips and Tools section we'll discuss
ways of addressing some of these behaviors,
if they come up.
Though it is important to familiarize yourself
with the symptoms of Alzheimer's disease and
other forms of dementia, it should not be
your focus during the program.
In fact, in our programs we never mention
Alzheimer's disease. Our goal is to create
an experience where the presence of the disease
is minimized and people of all abilities are
able to engage and contribute on an equal
level.
So in subsequent sections we'll be focusing
mainly on what you can do, as the educator,
to create a successful program, one that suits
all abilities. But generally speaking, what
do successful educators do?
A successful educator does one or more of
the following at any given point during a
program.
First, they model positive behavior for the
group by setting an inviting tone, encouraging
experimentation, and by treating all participants
as equally valid contributors
They lead the experience, initiating the various
steps of a project and maintaining an overall
structure.
They also listen -- they listen to participants
comments so that they can better understand
their interests and motivations.
In addition to listening, they actively observe
participants, interpreting their processes
and determining where assistance is needed.
Educators prompt different modes of creation,
making suggestions and challenging participants
to try new things.
They also encourage: they provide validation
and specific feedback throughout the process.
And finally, they synthesize- they find and
highlight connections between ideas, comments
and artworks, providing continuity and cohesion
throughout the program.
In subsequent sections we'll talk practically
about how to accomplish all these things,
what they look like, and how they feed into
preparation and facilitation.
All in all, the project, the participants
and you as the educator are all equal factors
in the experience. Together you contribute
to a program that includes:
Generation and development of ideas and objects
Validation of individual contributions and
creations
Socialization among participants
And a general sense of sincerity and enjoyment
It is important to internalize these ideas
as you move forward as they profoundly affect
the experience you create.
ART MAKING
Educator Preparation
In this section we'll discuss how to prepare
for an art-making project.
We'll first discuss how to conceive of an
art-making project, by focusing on three specific
components of any project -- the materials,
action, and topic. We'll explain these three
components in detail and also introduce a
tool that allows you to combine them to generate
project ideas, called the Project Matrix.
Once we have discussed how to conceive of
a project, we'll then go through the things
you can prepare in advance, including a structure
and schedule for your program, an artwork
discussion, project examples, and your spaces
and supplies.
So, let's begin with conceiving of a project.
There are any number of approaches you could
take in your planning, but for our purposes
we have created a tool that will help you
easily generate projects that are focused
yet flexible. We call this tool the Project
Matrix, and it allows you to build projects
around three main components:
The first is your materials- the actual items
that participants will be working with,
the second is your action- how participants
will work with with those materials, how specifically
they will manipulate them.
And the third is your topic -- the broader
idea that participants will explore or interpret
through the creative process.
These three project components work in tandem
to form the substance of your project and
also the parameters that give the experience
structure.
Let's look at each of the three project components
more closely, beginning with materials.
The materials are the items that participants
will use to create their artworks. There are
a myriad of possible materials that you can
select from. Here's a selection of materials
that are represented in our collection at
MoMA. This is by no means an exhaustive list
but merely a few ideas to help you get started.
You can find inspiration for possible materials
by looking at different artists' practices,
or seeing what is available in art supply
stores or in your immediate surroundings.
There are even works in our collection that
incorporate chocolate or taxidermy animals.
All of which is to say that you don't need
to limit yourself to what are seen as traditional
art materials.
Take a moment to think about possible materials
that you might work with. Are there ones that
aren't represented in our list here?
Keep in mind that this list is fairly general;
there are varieties that exist within each
of the materials listed here. For instance,
there are various forms of paint -- watercolor,
gouache, acrylic, oil paint, egg tempera,
and so one.—all with their own properties
and histories.
On that note, take a minute to consider one
of the materials listed here and the various
sub-types available. For instance, what kinds
of paper are available? What kinds of different
cameras could you use?
Of all the materials available to you, you
will eventually choose one or a couple main
materials for your project. You may feel inclined
to provide a great variety of materials, but
we have found that this abundance can overwhelm
the creative process. Further, by narrowing
down the selection of materials for your project
you afford participants a more focused exploration
of your chosen materials' unique properties.
Overall, choose materials that are age appropriate.
Materials that are designed for use in schools
or geared towards young children may be seen
as infantilizing.
Also, be mindful of the physical difficulties
that might come with aging and select materials
that are accessible to individuals with limited
dexterity, trouble with fine motor skills
or reduced vision. Avoid items that might
be too small to handle or difficult to see,
such as little pieces of paper and fine wire.
We'll cover specific adaptations that can
be made to make some art supplies more accessible
in the Tips and Tools section of this video.
The next project element to consider is your
action. The action describes how your participants
will handle or manipulate the materials.
Here are some actions or processes that are
represented in our collection:
Some may be more familiar to you, like drawing
or painting, and some, like marking or performing
may be new points of departure.
This is by no means an exhaustive list and
it's derived from the actions undertaken by
artists in our collection. Again, take a moment
to come up with other actions that you could
employ.
Again, select one particular action in order
to provide guidance for an intentional exploration
of the material at hand. This allows for an
experience that is more detailed and descriptive
than merely quote "making" something.
In general, choose an action that everyone
is physically capable of doing. Again, think
about the abilities within your group.
In addition, you should select an action that
you can demonstrate or model clearly for your
participants. Your ability to explain and
provide a visual reference is essential, especially
if you are introducing an action that is unfamiliar
to participants.
The last component is the topic. A topic gives
additional scope and focus to your project;
it's the guiding idea that participants will
explore as they are working.
Some topics that we have explored in past
projects include more traditional subject
matter in art history, like:
Portraiture, including self-portraiture and
family portraiture and Landscape or Cityscapes
We've also facilitated in-depth explorations
of a single formal element, for instance line
and color.
But there are also a number of broader ideas
that you could consider, such as identity
and politics.
Again, this list is just a jumping off point.
Take some time to think about other possible
topics, including other formal elements, different
themes you notice in art history or the practice
of other artists, or broader ideas that interest
you or are most relevant to your audience
and setting.
Of all the possible topics, select one for
your project.
In general, choose a topic that:
Is narrow enough to provide focus to your
project. For example, just "people" as a topic
might be too undirected, but narrowing down
the category to family or friends provides
scope to participants' explorations.
At the same time, make sure your topic is
general enough to still allow for multiple
approaches. Projects that are too focused—for
instance asking participants to depict a specific
place and time as their topic, say the restaurant
where they celebrated their first anniversary
—may prohibit creative response.
And finally, choose a topic that is relevant
and accessible, and interesting to you as
the educator.
Now that we've considered each of the three
project components individually, let's put
them together, starting with materials and
action. You can see that some of these actions,
like photographing, are associated with a
particular material, like a camera. Others
are more open and can be used with any number
of different materials.
For instance, drawing. What does it look like
to draw with pencil- a more traditional approach-
as opposed to drawing with wire. What if you
draw with light? What if you use your body
to draw? Sometimes choosing a less obvious
pairing yields more interesting artworks.
Now let's add the final component—topic—in
with the other two. Here you have the full
Project Matrix.
From here you can select one of each of the
components, combining different materials,
actions, and topics to generate any number
of project ideas.
Here's a selection of projects that we've
implemented in the past:
We've asked participants to build a landscape
(specifically a cityscape) with pieces of
wood.
We've also asked participants to use newspaper
to create collages about political events.
We've asked participants to assemblage their
own personal objects -- bringing objects from
home -- to explore personal identity.
We've asked participants to make a print with
their body and ground charcoal as a way of
investigating abstract self-portraiture.
In the past we've asked participants to explore
the figure by drawing with wire.
We've also asked participants to investigate
line by spreading ink.
Take some time to think about other combinations
that you could try.
Again, we also encourage you to come up with
your own lists of possible materials, actions,
and topics, which will likely be better suited
to your interests and circumstances. As you
move forward you can continue to come up with
ideas based on your own experiences engaging
with art in cultural institutions, public
spaces, or at home.
So, using the project matrix as a tool we've
chosen the following project combination:
paper, collage, and portraiture. We'll stick
with for the rest of this video, explaining
the various steps of preparation and facilitation
throughout.
Again, the project matrix is meant to help
simplify the process of generating project
ideas, while also helping you to think of
ways of making art that might be less obvious
or straightforward.
Further, the Project Matrix enables you to
start with whichever component makes the most
sense for you. For example, you can look at
the materials you have on hand, choose one
specifically to focus on, and build a project
from there. Alternatively, if you are thinking
about the particular themes of a special exhibition
you can start by choosing a topic and then
choose a material and action that will help
participants explore that topic.
Of course, not every combination that you
come up with will necessarily work as a project.
Overall, design projects that are:
Geared toward all levels of artistic skill.
For example, a project that asks participants
to draw life-like portraits of one another
using pastels may be intimidating and frustrating.
There are certainly other options that are
better suited for the artistic skill level
of your average adult and will be more enjoyable.
Design projects that are feasible in the time
allotted. For example, a large landscape made
using oil paint would be difficult to complete
in a 2-hour session, as that particular material
would need far longer to dry.
Along those same lines, make sure your project
is realistic considering the amount of staff
you have on hand. There may be materials,
actions, and topics that together will require
continued guidance or assistance from staff.
Be mindful of your ratio of staff to participants
when choosing those components.
And finally, design a project that is interesting
to you as the educator. Use your own interest
or excitement level as a gauge. If you're
not interested in the project, then don't
expect others to be.
If your project meets all these criteria then
it is more likely to be successful and enjoyable.
That said, your group will inevitably have
diverse preferences, varying experience with
art, a range of cognitive abilities. Accordingly,
expect that some participants might be hesitant,
no matter what project you design. All of
which is to say, be thoughtful in your planning
but don't try too hard to anticipate how everyone
will react, as you never really know.
Now that we've covered how to conceive of
a project, we will discuss how to prepare
for that project. We'll go through preparing
a structure and schedule, an artwork discussion,
project examples, as well as supplies and
spaces.
Let's begin with your program structure.
As a reminder, our typical programs take the
following form. We begin with an introduction
of the project's main ideas, followed by an
artwork discussion that relates to the project's
components: the materials, action, and topic.
From there we explain and demonstrate materials
and help participants think of how to get
started on their works before they begin creating.
We spend a significant amount of time making
art but we also save time at the end for group
discussion of participant artwork. We conclude
by sharing last thoughts and reflections on
the experience.
So, in planning your project, think about
these steps and how you will facilitate each
stage.
For instance, think about which ideas you
might want to introduce from the outset. Consider
your three project components. Will your chosen
materials, action or topic merit definition
or discussion at the beginning of your program
and if so, think about how you will explain
them. Will that require some additional research
in advance of your program?
For our example, again we've chosen paper,
collage, and portraiture. Paper is a commonplace
material, but participants will likely be
less familiar with collage and portraiture,
so we will plan to discuss these ideas at
the outset. In advance, we will better familiarize
ourselves with portraiture and collage processes,
and spend some time thinking about how to
define them in a straightforward manner.
Next, think about your artwork discussion
as it relates to your schedule. We'll cover
how to prepare the content of your discussion
shortly but for now, think about the number
of works you can discuss and how much time
you have to do so. Each individual artwork
discussion should last no longer than 10 minutes.
So, for our example we will plan to spend
about 20 minutes discussing artworks from
MoMA's collection, so we'll need to choose
3-4 artworks, max.
Think more specifically about your materials
and how you might demonstrate using them.
If a material is unfamiliar to you, spend
some time experimenting with it yourself in
advance of your program in order to get ideas
as to possible techniques that you might demonstrate.
For our example, we'll experiment with the
various papers we've selected, trying different
ways of folding, tearing, twisting, cutting,
and so on.
Think about how you might help participants
plan and then begin to execute their works.
What will you ask them to think about before
they start working? What will you ask them
to do first when it's time to execute their
plan?
So for our example, our topic is portraiture,
and that topic is fairly broad, so we'll need
to break that idea down into something more
manageable for participants. We'll plan to
start by asking participants to consider who
they'll be making a portrait of, and give
them some possible options. Once they've decided
who to depict we'll ask them to think more
specifically about which aspects of that person
they'd like to include in their portrait.
The remaining portions of your program will
be determined in large part by what transpires
over the course of your session. How you support
participants as they are making will be determined
by their process and needs, and the discussion
of participant works and your final thoughts
will grow out of what you observe and discuss
during the program.
Thinking about how you'll move through each
of these steps ahead of time will allow you
to facilitate your program effectively and
confidently. In the Leading a Project section
of this video you can see clips of us executing
all of these steps, continuing with our collage
portraiture project.
As we mentioned before, toward the beginning
of your session you'll facilitate an inquiry-based
discussion of about 2-4 established artworks.
This discussion is meant to provide insight
into your project components as well as inspiration
for participants' art-making.
To find these artworks, look online- on museum
or gallery websites, especially, as they have
higher quality images than those found on
other websites. You can also think about using
reproductions found in art books or posters.
In general, choose artworks that:
Employ the same components -- that is, the
same materials, topic and action -- that your
project employs.
Show variety in their approach to those components,
so participants are exposed to multiple perspectives
on your chosen materials, action, and topic.
Exhibit a range of complexity, thus broadening
participants' notion of what is acceptable
and accomplishable.
And are clearly legible in reproduction, if
that is what you'll be using.
So to return to our collage portraiture project,
the works that we've chosen in relation to
this project are:
A detail from Henri Matisse's multi-panel
collage, "The Swimming Pool," made in 1952.
This section depicts a horizontal figure collaged
from pieces of painted paper that have been
mounted onto burlap.
Romare Bearden's "Patchwork Quilt," from 1970.
Bearden used cut and pasted cloth and paper
to depict a figure reclining on a divan with
a patchwork quilt draped behind her.
Chuck Close's "Phyllis" from 1982, a black-and-white
collage of a woman's face, who looks straight
out at the viewer.
And finally, Lara Schnitger's [short "I"]
"Ciara" from the year 2000, which shows the
head and torso of a woman. This work was created
using colorful, decorative papers cut and
pasted to depict both the woman and her surroundings.
All of these works approach our three project
components- paper, collage, and portraiture-
in different ways.
For example, let's consider our topic, portraiture.
The title of Schnitger's work suggests a portrait
of a specific person, Ciara. Matisse's work,
on the other hand, gives us no sense that
this is a specific person, as he has abstracted
his figure. It is therefore a less traditional
kind of portrait.
In terms of our material, paper, Bearden employs
decorative patterns in his choice of materials,
while Matisse uses simpler solids.
And in terms of our final component, collage,
you can see that Matisse has collaged very
few pieces of paper in comparison with Chuck
Close's more dense arrangement.
Once you've selected your artworks, think
more about how you will prepare to facilitate
a conversation about them. While there are
many things you could discuss within any given
work, your focus should be on the elements
that most relate to your project and its components.
First, look closely in order to identify these
components.
Look for evidence of the materials, the process
or action undertaken by the artist, or their
approach to the topic. In addition, notice
the formal decisions that the artist has made,
like how they've employed or arranged lines,
shapes, forms or colors. Consider how all
of these elements come together to create
an overall mood or effect.
Pinpoint a couple of elements that you find
important and craft questions that will help
participants notice and describe them.
For example, in the Close work I am initially
struck by the texture. I want participants
to think about how they might create a sense
of texture in their own works. So I might
plan to say something like, "Describe the
surface of this work. Does it seem smooth
or rough? Let's think more specifically about
the individual pieces of paper Close used,
how would you describe their edges?"
In addition, I'd want participants to notice
how Close built up his surface by layering
pieces of paper on top of one another and
overlapping them, so I might ask something
like, "How are the pieces of paper arranged?
Does this image seem light to you, or dense?"
Alternatively, what strikes me most about
the Matisse work is that he created a figure
seemingly in motion, and used very few pieces
of paper to do so. I'm going to want participants
to notice these aspects of the work so they,
too, might think about depicting movement
as a viable option for their own collages.
As such, I'll ask something like "What does
this figure seem to be doing?" "Does he seem
to be moving or staying still?" "How did the
artist create that sense of movement?" And,
finally, "roughly how many pieces of paper
did the artist use to create that effect?"
In addition to looking closely, do some research
about the artworks and the artist who made
them. Find detailed information about each
work's materials, the action or process employed,
and the artist's approach to the topic. Learn
what you can about the artist's motivations
behind making these choices. Consider how
this work relates to the artist's practice
overall.
As you're deciding which art historical points
you might share during your discussion, prioritize
that which is most relevant to your project
and what you will be asking participants to
do.
So going back to my Matisse, through the course
of my research, I learned about his process
in making this work -- that he generally cut
the shapes out freehand, using a small pair
of scissors and saving both the item cut out
and remaining scraps of paper. Then he and
his assistants would painstakingly arrange
and re-arrange his loose pieces of cut paper
before pinning and then finally pasting them
down. I'll prioritize sharing this information
during my discussion because it relates to
the collage process that I'll be asking participants
to try. I also found out a bit more about
his overall practice -- that he started his
career in the early 20th century working with
painting and sculpture and didn't turn to
collage until later in life.
Prior to your program create an artwork that
employs your project components, which will
serve as an example during your program.
Creating a project example allows you to go
through the steps of the project yourself,
which will better familiarize you with the
process you'll be asking participants to undergo,
and also allows you to identify and resolve
any potential trouble spots.
Examples should demonstrate various techniques
or approaches to your project components and
should represent what is realistically possible
given the timeframe and supplies you'll provide.
Don't utilize materials or spend more time
than will be available to participants.
For our project we've created two example
works.
I created a portrait of Laurel. I wanted to
provide an example of a portrait of a person
I knew. I used scissors to create the various
components of Laurel's face, hair, and clothing.
I created a portrait of an imaginary figure,
a frog prince. I opted to create my portrait
by just tearing and folding paper, forgoing
the use of scissors. I wanted to create a
finished project employing a more accessible
method of working with paper.
On the day of your program, prepare your spaces
and supplies. Arrange your space in a way
that allows all participants room to work
and to interact with each other. Your set
up should afford you access to each participant,
so that you'll be able to interact with them
individually during the program.
Gather all the materials necessary and organize
them in a way that will allow you to easily
access and distribute them later on.
So for our program we will gather different
varieties of paper, making sure to account
for the background paper that participants
can use as a surface as well as various kinds
of colored and decorative papers that they'll
use to create an image. We'll go ahead and
cut some of that paper into different shapes,
in case anyone prefers to work with pre-existing
pieces. We'll also pull out scissors and glue
and plan to arrange our tables in a U-shape
so participants can see us and each other.
In general, when conceiving of and preparing
to lead an art-making project:
Develop a project that is both focused and
flexible. Whether or not you choose to use
the Project Matrix in your planning, projects
with defined parameters are easier to follow
for participants, and easier for you to facilitate
clearly.
Consider the accessibility of your project.
Choose project components that can be clearly
explained and that are engaging for participants
with a diverse range of physical and cognitive
abilities, as well as varying levels of artistic
expertise.
Choose artworks and create project examples
that will inspire creative thinking and variety
of approach, not discourage personalized exploration
and response.
Combine your project components in a way that
is interesting to you as the educator. You'll
be having your own experience with your project
-- both in your preparation and when you facilitate
the program -- so you should be excited about
it.
Keeping these things in mind as you conceive
of and prepare for your project will allow
you to prompt individualized artistic explorations
without over-determining participant experience.
ART-MAKING
LEADING A PROJECT
In this section we'll cover how to lead an
art-making project, which includes the following
steps:
Welcome -- setting up the experience
Discussing Artworks -- facilitating a conversation
about works of art for inspiration
Explaining Materials -- defining and demonstrating
the materials that will be used
Starting the Art-Making Process -- helping
participants begin to create
Supporting the Art-Making Process -- continuing
to support individual participants and the
group once everyone has started to work
Sharing Works Created-- presenting and discussing
participant artwork, and finally
Conclusion and Project Extension- providing
final thoughts on the experience and suggestions
going forward
This structure is meant to provide you with
a flexible outline for facilitating your project.
It is grounded in prevailing practices in
museum education. We use it as a guide for
structuring our programs for people with Alzheimer's
disease and their carepartners but also with
other Museum audiences, because it allows
for various forms of interpretation and creation,
no matter participants' level of ability,
and connects the art-making process to ideas
and works in MoMA's collection.
In this section we'll cover how to structure
an art-making program in general, without
focusing too directly on the specific needs
of individuals with Alzheimer's disease.
Information pertaining specifically to this
audience will be covered in the next section,
Tips and Tools, as will ways of creating a
supportive and validating environment. The
tone you set is just as important as the structure
you follow.
Further, this structure can accommodate many
different kinds of projects. The materials,
action, and topic that form the parameters
of your particular project, may determine
how quickly you move through certain parts.
For instance, in a project where the materials
are intuitive and the process straightforward,
say arranging adhesive stickers on paper,
your material explanation might be much quicker.
On the other hand, multi-step project like
block-printing might require a more prolonged
explanation.
As we go through we'll continue with our example
project employing paper, collage, and portraiture,
including clips from a program that Laurel
and I co-taught in our studio spaces. In a
typical MoMA program there is one lead educator,
with additional support staff. But, for the
sake of filming, we taught this session together.
Let's get into the details of leading a project,
beginning with welcome.
To begin your program, welcome participants
with a relaxed and inviting tone and orient
the group to the experience. Introduce yourself
and outline the upcoming project. As we discussed
in the Educator Preparation section of this
video, you should already have your materials
set up in an organized and accessible fashion,
so as to be able to engage with participants
as soon as they walk in.
After introducing yourself and the project,
give a brief outline for your program. Frame
participants' expectations as to what is to
come. Additionally, it's important to communicate
the goals of the experience-- to explore and
experiment as you work on an image or object--
and to emphasize what is possible in the time
allotted.
Here's a clip of Laurel framing the session
and communicating its goals:
We're going to spend about an hour and a half
today working. We're going to start out by
discussing a few works of art from our collection,
then we're going to work for a bit, and then
at the end we'll have an opportunity to see
what everyone else has made and to share a
bit with each other.
Collage can be a really labor-intensive process,
and some of the works we're going to talk
about today took months and months to create.
So, it's just to say that we're not necessarily
going to make the next "museum masterpiece"
since we only have an hour and a half, we
can only accomplish so much. But the goals
are just to experiment with the materials,
and explore some of the ideas that we're going
to be discussing, and to see what we come
up with.
You can see that Laurel encouraged participants
to use the time to explore and create. She
also stressed that there was only a limited
amount of time within which to work. This
was not meant to limit participants but rather
to take the pressure off and encourage experimentation.
From there, elaborate the project's focus
and explain the key project components. As
mentioned in the Educator Preparation section
of this video, you should decide ahead of
time which project components merit definition.
Here's Meryl elaborating on two components:
Today we're going to be doing a paper collage
project as a way of exploring portraiture.
Collage -- I just found this out -- the word
collage comes from the French work "to glue",
and it involves taking parts of things --
"little bits and scraps" --
exactly, just like Carol said, little bits
of this and that, right. The materials can
be anything; we're going to work with paper
today, some artists use fabric, some use newspapers
or magazines. Taking little bits of this and
that, like Carol was saying, rearranging them,
and making a new thing. That's what collage
is.
The second thing we're exploring today, as
I mentioned, is portraiture. So what do you
think of when I say the word "portraiture",
what's that?
I see Carol going like this, so we're on to
something
It's a real formal focus on one particular
thing, and really paying attention to that
object.
Absolutely right. So portraits are normally
very focused, they're just of one thing, and
what is that one thing that they're normally
of?
Person's face
A face, exactly. Marty, you were going to
say that too? Exactly, right. Some portraits
are very lifelike and others can be a bit
more abstract or just capture one or two of
the physical attributes that define a person.
And we're going to look at a couple examples
in a second of both of those different kinds
of portraits.
You can see in the clip that Meryl defined
the ideas of collage and portraiture. Before
giving her definitions, however, she asked
participants if they had heard of or experimented
with these ideas before, honoring their prior
knowledge and experiences.
Once you've introduced your project, you will
lead a short inquiry-based discussion about
your preselected artworks. The artwork discussion
is meant to provide inspiration and to contextualize
the experience within a larger framework of
artistic practice.
Distribute and discuss each work one-by-one.
If possible, have a large central image around
which you can unite the group, and also pass
out reproductions to each participant so that
they can look at the works more closely and
continue to refer to them throughout the experience.
As you start your discussion, explain to participants
that you'll be showing examples of artworks
that employ the same materials, action or
topic that they will also be exploring, that
you plan to spend about 5-10 minutes discussing
each of these works and that you're eager
to hear their thoughts.
Here's an example:
We're going to look at a few works from the
collection so we can get some inspiration
for our own art-making process. The artists
that we're going to show you have employed
different materials, have used different processes
of building the works that they've created.
So you can use their ideas to, you know, help
you get started or for inspiration, but you
can also feel free to depart from what they've
done.
In that clip Laurel explained the purpose
of looking at artworks, though she indicated
that participants had a choice as to whether
or not they would like to incorporate the
techniques viewed into their own making. It
is important to emphasize to participants
that they are not meant to just copy the style
of one artist.
As you move through the discussion, ask questions
that prompt explorations of the particular
approach to the materials, action, or topic
within each work. Point participants to the
formal properties of the work, specific decisions
made by the artist, the resulting image and
overall effect.
Here's a clip from Laurel's discussion of
our final artwork, Chuck Close's "Phyllis".
Looking closely at our last work of art, do
you have a sense of how it might be made or
what materials are that this artist has used?
Crepe paper
Gray paper?
Crepe
Oh yeah, that textured paper, crepe paper,
right?
Confetti! And Carol, what made you think of
confetti?
It's small and round
Does everyone notice that there are little
round pieces of paper of different kind of
shades of white to black, that have been layered
over each other to build up the image of this
person?
But it's also interesting --
--you can put it wherever you want
Yeah, you can put it wherever you want, exactly.
As Carol's saying -- and this is exactly what
we'll be doing -- we'll be layering and arranging
pieces of paper to create an image of a person
or another kind of figure.
There are not smooth edges on the paper. They're
all kind of, a little bit uneven, an effect
or they're serrated in some fashion, so that
adds an additional interest to this composition.
Yeah, and I'm going to repeat back what Lynne
said. It's interesting that the edges of the
little pieces of paper that are used to construct
this image aren't perfectly even. It's not
like they're cut up squares or smooth, they're
really rough, exactly, and in fact when we're
making our works today you can think about
that. You can sort of fold or tear and think
about different ways of manipulating the paper
to get a certain effect like that.
In the clip Laurel asked questions that encouraged
participants to examine the materials used
in the work, in this case paper, and then
to think of how they were applied to create
the image of "Phyllis." She also linked participants'
observations about Close's choice of paper
to choices that they might consider when working
later on. It is important to make this direct
link, always situating the artworks shown
during the discussion within the context of
the art-making process to come.
Remember, when facilitating a discussion about
artworks at the beginning of your art-making
program, the emphasis is less on building
a personal and collective interpretation of
the work, considering its broader significance
in art and world history, than on asking questions
that prompt close attention to the materials,
action, or topic. Encouraging participants
to think about how something is made will
lay the groundwork for their own making.
Once you've concluded your discussion, introduce
and explain your materials. Review the various
materials that you have available and demonstrate
as necessary.
Here's an example of Meryl reviewing our project's
materials:
So everyone will get the same background paper,
and then we're also going to be working with
a variety of colored and patterned paper.
And they have different textures and weights,
so they fold and tear differently.
You can tell, actually, Carol, that this paper
is very easy to fold. It's very light, if
you want to hold it. And so that's something
to think about as you're making your own work.
as well, right, the paper that rips easily
or tears easily versus the paper that is a
little weightier.
And then, of course, we've gone ahead and
precut some paper here as well, and so everyone
should have some of this in front of them.
There's solid colors on the one half and then
some of this precut pattern paper on the other
half, so that might be nice to try to experiment
with too.
You can see that Meryl clearly explained the
kinds of paper that were provided and their
varying properties. Don't assume that everyone
is an expert. You should explain what is available,
even if the materials seem straightforward.
Once you've introduced the materials, explain
a bit more about how to use or manipulate
them.
One way to do this is to show participants
your project example.
Here is a clip of Laurel showing an example
of a collage portrait she made prior to the
program:
And so here's an example I made just be tearing
and folding. If you look at some of the details,
you'll notice that I folded this crown into
the spikes, I made a bit of a frog prince
here today. And then ripped the eyes out and
the nose to create all of the facial features,
and then again sort of folded this patterned
paper at the bottom to create a sense of his
collar.
In her explanation Laurel described some of
the ways that she used the paper to create
aspects of the Frog Prince's body and dress.
She also emphasized that the work was created
without using scissors.
You can also create or at least start to create
a work in front of participants, in order
to show firsthand ways of working with the
materials.
Here is an example:
So today I'd like to make a portrait of Meryl.
Then what I'm going to start with is just
to do her face -- cut out a face for her.
But you know, Meryl sometimes when she gets
really excited or maybe is like a little a
bit anxious she turns bright red, so I'm going
to do her face in bright red. So you can just
cut out a shape that, you know, she's got
ears, but then if I'm thinking maybe I want
to do her hair, today she wore her hair curly
which I really like and I want to see if I
can maybe get some different textures in there,
right, some shape and some depth. So maybe
I want to use a few different kinds of reddish
browns or maybe I'll get even less lifelike
and throw some purple in and just sort of
layer them. And for these I'm just going to
rip, maybe, and maybe I'll do a little bit
of an accordion fold to get some of the curl,
the texture. So now you can see my Meryl is
sort of coming to life.
In that clip Laurel quickly planned and started
a work, narrating her thoughts and process.
She modeled how you might get started, by
cutting out a face, and then demonstrated
a few different techniques, including cutting,
folding and tearing. Moreover, in her brevity
and low-key manner she implicitly conveyed
that the task of art-making was not meant
to be intimidating.
You can also demonstrate techniques without
actually starting a work, and ask participants
to try them out with you as you go. This is
an especially good idea if you are working
with a material that is new and unfamiliar
to participants, as it gives them a chance
to try things out before working on a final
product.
Distribute relevant materials, but don't pass
out everything at this point, as some materials
might serve as a distraction during your demonstration.
After you've introduced and explained your
materials, begin the art-making process. Give
participants an opportunity to plan their
work and provide some instruction or guidance
on how to begin. It can be difficult to transition
from discussion and instruction to creating
a work, so providing initial prompts can ease
participants into the art-making process.
While the particular prompts you give will
be specific to your project, it's generally
a good idea not to give too many directions
at once. Instead, your initial prompts should
be concise and concrete.
Let's take a look:
The first thing to do as you're thinking about
creating your own collages is to decide who
you want to be making a collage of -- you
want a person, exactly -- who you want to
be making your collage portrait of. So you
can make a self portrait, you can choose someone
in this room, like I chose Laurel. Sometimes
it's nice to have a visual reference right
on hand. Or, you know, you can choose an imaginary
person -- our definition of portraiture is
loose today. You can also feel free to abandon
your ideas later if the materials sort of
take you in a different direction. For example,
if I want to make a portrait of my Mom but
I really like that shiny paper and my mother
becomes an astronaut, that's fine too.
So maybe take a second to think about who
you want to make a portrait of, some of their
defining physical attributes, or something
about their personality and turn to the person
next to you and let them know who you think
you're going to be creating a picture of today.
So, Marty and Susie you said you're going
to work together, who are you going to be
making today? Okay, so Marty is going to be
making a collage portrait of Susie with Susie's
input. And then the second thing to do, after
you've chosen your person, is to think about
if you want to make just a face or a bust,
like in the Chuck Close, right, or if you
want to make a whole body or even, you know,
a body in action the way that we saw with
the Matisse work here. Right, so again, something
else to consider: who you're going to be making
and what part of their body you want to be
depicting.
In that clip you can see that Meryl asked
participants to consider who might be the
subject of their portrait and presented a
few possible options. She also kept the process
open, reiterating that it's okay to change
your mind midway. After having participants
discuss their ideas, she then asked them to
further develop their plan and consider what
part of the person they wanted to focus on.
Indeed, breaking up these two ideas better
facilitated participant planning. It is generally
best to ask participants to consider one idea
at a time.
Further, by asking participants to discuss
their ideas together Meryl encouraged continued
conversation. Sharing thoughts with another
person also creates a memory prosthesis, which
is helpful for those with short-term memory
loss.
Once participants have an idea of what they
will make, make sure they have all the necessary
materials to start their work. Walk around
to each participant and reiterate the prompts
individually. Often, participants need a bit
of personal attention at the outset to help
get them started. Further, you can get a sense
of where they are going with their project
so that you can return to them constructively
later on in the process.
Throughout the art-making process, continue
to support participants. Encourage them as
they work, prompting different avenues of
exploration and assist participants when necessary.
Begin by moving around freely and observing
participants as they work. See if anyone needs
any additional materials or other supplies
and assess the various members of the group
to see if anyone might benefit from more targeted
assistance.
As their projects are developing, ask participants
about the choices they've made and the direction
they are going with their work. Provide constructive
and specific encouragement, incorporating
what they might have said and what you've
noticed. You can also touch on comments they
might have made during the artwork discussion,
reintroducing what they said and connecting
it to their process.
You can also provide participants with a range
of options as to how they might move forward,
encouraging experimentation and exploration.
Here's an example:
We can also trying moving them around, arranging
them.
Yeah, yeah. Maybe that's better.
Maybe that's better?
Yeah, I think so.
Well, you show me and I'll just do the gluing
for you.
I think it would be better on the side.
I like that you had it sort of looking over
to the side.
How's was that? Was that the first pose?
In that clip Meryl suggested that Carole play
with the placement of her figure's eyes, moving
them around and trying different arrangements
before making a decision.
Prior to that, Carol and I had spent some
time thinking about how to make the eyes.
We tried cutting one eye out and tearing the
other to see which one she preferred.
As participants are working, you should provide
suggestions as to how they might accomplish
a particular aspect of their work or expand
the techniques they are using. Provide a practical
visual reference by demonstrating individually
how to achieve or incorporate what it is you
are suggesting. Sometimes it's not enough
to just mention a method of working, but physically
demonstrating can be helpful.
You can also reintroduce one or some of the
artworks discussed earlier. Highlight similarities
and differences in order to generate new ways
of working or validate a participant's process
thus far. But just remember that if you are
going to refer to something you've seen or
discussed earlier you should have a visual
reference on hand as a reminder.
As people are working, hold up works in progress
so that participants can see other approaches.
Encourage participants to look at each other's
work throughout the session.
Here's an example:
Do you mind if I hold yours up to show everyone?
Well look at that, that's gorgeous!
So I just want to show everyone an example
of someone's work so far. Lynne has been doing
a portrait of Manny.
Wow, that's great!
Not very good.
Ty is a tough critic but I really like how
you've already gotten his beard and the texture
of his hair on top of his head.
In that clip Laurel got everyone's attention
before sharing Lin's work-in-progress, thus
maintaining group cohesion and prompting exchange
among participants.
As time winds down, let participants know
how long they have left to work so they can
finish up before sharing with the group.
About 15 minutes before the end of your program
bring the art-making to a close and give participants
a chance to present and discuss their works
with each other. This discussion allows for
individual validation and strengthens connections
among participants.
Here's an example of Laurel initiating this
step:
I know that some of you guys are still working,
and again we'll send you home with some of
the supplies so you can continue to work at
home if you like, but for now let's see what
everyone has made, okay?
In that clip you could see that Laurel expressed
enthusiasm at seeing participants' work and
reassured everyone that they could continue
to work later on if need be.
Go around to each participant and invite them
to present their work to the group, or ask
if you can share on their behalf. If a participant
is willing to share, ask them about their
process and/or the decisions they've made
and pull from conversations you had as they
were working.
Let's take a look:
And then I want to show Marty's portrait of
Suzy.
Surreal portrait of Suzy.
The surreal portrait of Suzy, is what Marty
said.
Oh, that's nice! Oh yeah!
So this is Marty's portrait of Suzy. So Marty,
what were some of the aspects of Suzy that
you wanted to capture, besides her hair?
Her vibrancy, with the colors. And her openness,
through the length of the paper...and the
diversity.
The diversity. And then the.. vibrancy you
said also, with the choice of paper. It looks
like you did choose papers that had some sparkle
and had some bright colors, vivid colors.
It's very vibrant.
And I think the texture that you created also
plays into that. And Suzy, do you see a little
bit of yourself in it?
I'm very flattered.
In that clip Laurel asked Marty to discuss
some of Suzy's particular characteristics
that he wanted to capture or communicate,
linking them to his choice of paper and use
of texture.
In addition, you can ask participant's to
title their work, and to provide some explanation
for that title, in order to gain greater insight
into what they've made and why.
Throughout, draw comparisons between participant
artworks. Find and comment on similarities
or differences in how participants approach
your project components. You can facilitate
comparison by displaying the works together,
either by placing them on a table or adhering
them to the wall. This also allows participants
to see works made by those who may not want
to share individually in front of the group.
Once you've finished discussing participant
work, bring your program to a close. Summarize
the experience and consider how participants
might continue with the ideas explored.
Thank everyone for their time and participation.
Share final thoughts or observations from
the session, as well as any logistical information,
such as ways of transporting artworks, or
information about future programs.
If possible, display artworks in an exhibition.
This public forum allows for further validation
and extends the experience beyond the time
in the studios. It connects your work and
that of your participants to a broader audience.
Display works in a quality fashion and be
intentional in your curation. Title your show
and provide an explanation of the ideas and
processes explored by participants, using
language that communicates the value and sincerity
of the work. If possible, hold an opening
reception for the show so that participants
can share their experience with family and
friends.
In general, as you lead your art-making project,
keep the following in mind:
Provide some initial structure but allow the
project to flow
Customize prompts, materials, and assistance
based on individual preference and ability,
and
Encourage both individual and group exploration
By internalizing these ideas you will allow
participants to create original, personal
works of art that are connected to broader
ideas in art and art history.
ART MAKING
TIPS AND TOOLS
In this section, we'll go over general tips
and tools for successfully facilitating your
art-making program. We'll first share with
you some practical tips for leading your program
and then discuss some challenging scenarios
that may come up and ways you can address
them.
So, let's begin with general facilitation
strategies. No matter the group you're working
with, it can sometimes be difficult to balance
the interests, abilities, and personalities
of each of the participants. We'll next discuss
some general facilitation techniques that
will help to foster an environment that encourages
individual creation and group cohesion:
The first technique is to animate the experience,
yourself.
Show your enthusiasm. Think of the experience
as an opportunity to be your most performative
self. But make sure your level of animation
does not come across as insincere.
Also, share personal information about yourself
in order to make participants feel more comfortable
with you. Doing so makes the whole experience
feel less formal or intimidating.
In the same vein, ask participants to respond
to the project by drawing on their own personal
experiences, when appropriate. Also, use what
you know about them as individuals to prompt
or validate their process.
Let's take a look at this:
So I, you know, Carole and I were having trouble
coming up with what person to make but Carole
was a teacher and loved kids, still loves
kids, so we decided on a baby. And do you
want to talk a little more about some of these
decisions, Carole? Carole, you mentioned that
we were tearing all of this paperÉ
Yeah, I do like torn paper for something like
this.
I agree.
In that clip, you saw Meryl sharing Carol's
motivation for choosing to create a portrait
of a child.
As Carol and I were working I encouraged her
to draw on her own life experiences when trying
to decide what kind of figure to create.
Address participants by name and make eye
contact.
Don't be afraid to address people directly
-- use their name when you are working with
them or when you ask them to share their opinions
or ideas. Make eye contact in order to convey
sincere engagement.
As you are facilitating your program, repeat
often. This includes repeating participant
comments back to the whole group during your
group discussions, as well as reiterating
prompts and guidelines frequently, both to
the group as a whole and one-on-one. This
strategy ensures that those with short-term
memory loss or those with hearing difficulties
are not at a disadvantage.
Let's take a look at Laurel using this technique
during the artwork discussion:
What's interesting also about the little pieces
of paper is that they're not smooth edges
on the paper, they're all kind of a little
bit uneven. They have a ripple effect or they're
serrated in some fashion, so that adds an
additional interest to this composition.
Yeah, and I'm gonna repeat back what Lynne
said. She said it's interesting that the edges
of the little pieces of paper that are used
to construct this image aren't perfectly even,
it's not like they're cut up little squares
or smooth. They're really rough, exactly.
You can see that Laurel first told the group
she was going to repeat Lin's comment, and
then did so, in order to ensure that everyone
heard and understood.
During your facilitation, try not to mention
materials, techniques, artists or artworks
that aren't immediately visible to participants.
If you want to bring something up that's not
visually available, try to find or create
a visual reference. Only reference that which
can be seen and understood by everyone, otherwise
you put those with short term memory loss
or those newer to art-making at a disadvantage.
As much as possible, try to invest quality
time with each individual as they are working.
Pull up a chair so that you're at eye level.
Ask the participant about their artistic decisions,
give feedback or give them choices on how
to proceed. By sitting down with each participant
you communicate your interest in their work
and gain better understanding of their interests
and processes, which will play into the discussion
of participant artwork to come.
Though some people may need more assistance
than others, try to check in with everyone
at some point. By divvying up your attention
in order to connect with each participant
you maintain an environment where everyone
is treated equally.
Encourage participants to experiment freely
and enjoy the process, even if that means
deviating from the project parameters. Don't
over-direct or over-determine someone's art-making
process by forcing them to work in the ways
that you had anticipated.
Right, it's a fine line between helpfully
assisting and making decisions for someone.
In emphasizing process and encouraging experimentation,
you may get a wider range of final products,
but this is a good thing and you should embrace
it!
When responding to participants' works, go
beyond saying that you quote "like it." Look
closely at the work and identify the choices
that the participant has made and validate
them specifically.
General feedback, like "that's really nice"
can come off as superficial and patronizing.
Let's take a look:
One thing that I really liked is that you
were sure to depict me here and now, and in
my exact same outfit even with the example
artworks in the background.
The tilt of the head is so lifelike! It's
excellent, and the hairline...
You can see that Laurel has not just generally
praised Ed's work, but found something specific
-- that he provided context for his portrait
by including the details of the room-- to
comment on and draw others' attention to.
Throughout the program, create opportunities
for exchange between participants. Remember,
while all participants work individually,
this is also a social experience.
For example, encourage participants to look
at and comment on one another's work throughout
the program by holding up works in progress
for consideration. If some people finish early,
encourage them to walk around and observe
others. As participants finish, collect all
works in one place so group-members can easily
admire and compare them. Point out commonalities
during your discussion of participant works.
Let's take a look at Laurel encouraging the
group to compare two works at the end of the
program:
I wanted to show these together because I
like how you both used minimal facial features
and created these facial expressions on both
of your figures. And I like these are all
torn and cut and there's something kind of
soft and squishy about your baby, Carole,
and then for Ty's work all these angular features
of his nose, and his eyes, and his eyebrows.
And the horns, how could I forget the horns!
He has a very satanic face.
You can see that we held up both works so
as to draw attention to similarities and differences
in the two participants' approaches.
Throughout your program, maintain a degree
of lightness and humor. Remember, one of the
goals is to create a fun experience where
participants are able to relax and enjoy themselves.
From the start and throughout, set a tone
that communicates these goals.
There can be a level of insecurity or intimidation
that comes with art-making, especially if
it's new to some of your participants. Additionally,
the symptoms of Alzheimer's disease may create
moments of embarrassment. But by maintaining
a light and relaxed tone, any moments of awkwardness
or embarrassment will be minimized as you
move forward and stay focused on the project
at hand.
As with any audience, there are a number of
challenging scenarios that may come up as
you're facilitating your program. We'll next
go through a number of situations we've encountered
and suggestions for how to address them.
So the first one that we often experience,
no matter the group, is that participants
can be slow to get started in the art-making
process. It can be a challenge to switch gears
from conversation to creation. After you've
presented the materials and guidelines it
is helpful to walk around the group and prompt
participants one-on-one. Sometimes participants
just need this additional cue to know that
it's time to get started.
If you notice that a participant is still
having trouble beginning their work ask if
they have the materials they need. Once they
do, re-demonstrate how to use them one on
one. Speak to them at eye level to be sure
you are connecting.
If that doesn't work, start to make suggestions
for how to begin. So, for example with this
collage project, one of our participants was
slow to get started. After I re-iterated the
prompt and redemonstrated the materials, I
asked if I could work with her. We chatted
and it became clear that she was stuck on
deciding who to depict but she was sure she
wanted to create a bust, not a whole body.
So I suggested that regardless of who she
ended up making, we'd need to start with a
head.
She agreed and so I handed her some scissors
and offered her a range of flesh-tone paper.
I asked her to choose one of the papers and
to cut it into an oval. For her, this initial
suggestionâ to make a head -- paired with
clear, concise instructions -- to cut the
paper into an oval -- was enough and she took
off with the project on her own after that.
But if she had still not responded, I could
have cut or torn a number of shapes that resembled
eyes, noses or lips myself, and asked her
to make a selection and arrange them to her
liking. Then, if she had still been hesitant,
I could have placed the first piece onto the
paper for her, and encouraged her to build
her image from there.
Right, if it comes to it, try making the first
mark or the first move with whatever material
it is you're using merely to break up the
intimidation of the blank surface. Personally
I even find it easier to work off of a preexisting
image or a mark than to start from nothing.
Once you've made a suggestion as to how to
get started, move on and give your participant
time to process the idea. Don't hover, but
check back later.
Generally, if a participant is not taking
to the project, encourage collaboration and
take a more active role -- offer to work with
the person or suggest that they work with
some one else.
Some participants may have difficulty using
your materials but there are a few things
that you can do to make them easier to work
with.
First, take steps to ensure that participants
can see the materials clearly by increasing
the contrast between the table surface and
your materials. For example, don't use white
paper on a white table.
In general, be mindful of the size of your
materials. Very small items or utensils may
be difficult to see and/or hold.
You may need to find ways to make the materials
easier to handle. For example, if you are
working with clay you can warm it up with
your hands to make it softer or more malleable.
Or if you are working with wire, have multiple
gauges on hand so participants can choose
the one they're able to bend most easily.
Finally, encourage alternative ways to get
to the same end. For example, if participants
are having trouble with scissors, suggest
tearing or folding instead. It's easier and
the end result is the same. Or, find ways
to assist with this step ahead of time. For
instance, for our project, we pre-cut a variety
of paper.
If those adjustments don't work, find a way
to help execute the creative choices of a
participant more actively. For example, the
balsa foam we use for block printing workshops
can be difficult to carve for some. So, I
have had participants draw their work onto
the balsa foam and then I've gone through
after to deepen the lines, so as to ensure
a clear print.
You may work with a participant whose physical
limitations make independently creating their
own work impossible. In that case you can
act as their proxy, prompting them to make
decisions and then executing those decisions
for them. For example with collage portraiture,
you could ask the participant what color paper
they want for the various facial features,
then offer them a range of options in that
color, eventually cutting some options for
them to choose from in their selected hue.
You could then demonstrate possible arrangements
and ask which they prefer, and so on.
Don't make participants feel uncomfortable
about your assisting them. I even tell participants
that many contemporary artists today make
the creative decisions but have others carry
out the tasks.
The aesthetic decisions are the most important
part of the art-making process. Focus on them
and you'll highlight the participant's successes.
Another scenario we've seen is when participants
do not create something within the framework
you've provided. In short, who cares? The
diversity of your participant artworks represents
the degree to which you've allowed each individual
to exercise their unique creative agency.
Embrace these individual approaches and interpretations.
While you provide structure and guidance,
participants may prefer to engage on their
own terms and in their own way. If participants
deviate from the instructions, it's not a
failure on their end, nor a failure of the
project or facilitator, but just an honest
expression of that person's preferences.
You may be tempted to try and re-route participants
toward the instructions you've outlined, but
be wary of hindering someone's creative expression
-- we've seen good intention backfire, so
to speak. Instead, focus on the process behind
their product. Try pointing out something
about their work that is interesting to you,
and ask the participant about their aesthetic
choices, whether or not it's within the frame
of your project components. Encourage and
validate, no matter the final product.
Interest and abilities within any given group
may vary, and balancing those needs can be
challenging. One of the ways this most often
manifests is that some participants may finish
their project far before everyone else and
some don't finish at all within the allotted
time.
Be sure to have extra materials on hand ahead
of time so that if someone finishes early,
you can encourage them to start a second work.
Add some sort of adaptation to the guidelines
or make suggestions for how to do things differently
to keep the second endeavor fresh. For our
example, if a participant were to finish a
portrait of their husband's face, I might
then encourage them to start a new version,
but this time, depicting his whole body.
If participants are not interested in continuing
to work, suggest that they walk around and
look at other works or even assist you. No
matter what, encourage them to stay involved
in the group in some way.
Alternatively, if a participant does not finish
in time, be sure to include them in your group
discussion, sharing their piece as a "work
in progress." Send materials home with them
so that they may complete the work on their
own time.
Of course these are only a handful of the
challenging situations you could encounter.
Every time we teach there's a new challenge
and surprise and we're constantly learning
and improving our practices as educators.
In sum, remember to
Take the lead. You have the ability to inform
how participants engage through your approach
and demeanor. If you remain relaxed and flexible,
if you're enjoying yourself, sincerely appreciating
participant contributions, and setting a respectful
tone, then others will do the same.
Address and encourage each participant. Individualize
the art-making process by making adaptations
freely, based on each person's needs or interests.
Moreover, encourage each individual participant
to interpret your guidelines as they please.
Show genuine interest in participants' ideas
and decisions.
Foster connections between participants. Though
every participant may be working individually,
this is still a social experience. Take advantage
of the fact that everyone's in the same room
together. Encourage participants to learn
from one another and enjoy each other's company.
With these approaches in mind you'll be able
to facilitate your project in a way that minimizes
challenging moments and encourages varied
forms of creative engagement.